Voy a enseñarte sobre una bola giratoria excepto que no es una bola y no está girando hoy en Qiskit en el
aula hablaremos sobre esta propiedad cuántica llamada spin mirando el experimento que primero encontró evidencia para
ello bienvenido a Qiskit en el aula en esta serie usaremos Qiskit para explorar algunos conceptos fundamentales comúnmente
cubiertos en cursos relacionados con computación cuántica cada video también irá acompañado de un módulo interactivo
vinculado en la descripción a continuación así que asegúrate de verificar eso hoy estamos hablando sobre el experimento Stern Gerlach de 1922
es uno de los más famosos en la historia de la teoría cuántica porque demuestra tan claramente cómo funciona el spin cuántico
pero eso no es lo que Stern o Gerlach tenían la intención de mostrar el experimento fue diseñado para probar un nuevo modelo cuántico
del átomo llamado modelo de Bohr nombrado después de Niels Bohr quien lo propuso en 1913 en el modelo los electrones giraban alrededor
del núcleo en orbitales discretos y podían transitar entre esos orbitales absorbiendo o emitiendo
fotones cada orbital tenía un momento angular cuantizado que era un múltiplo entero de una pequeña constante fundamental
llamada h en los años 10 y 20 la mecánica cuántica era completamente nueva tan nueva
que ni siquiera se llamaba mecánica cuántica todavía así que no todos estaban convencidos del modelo de Bohr un físico
llamado Otto Stern lo odiaba llamaba al modelo una tontería e incluso amenazó con dejar la física si Bohr estuviera
en lo correcto Stern estaba tan decidido a demostrar que el modelo era incorrecto que se le ocurrió una manera ingeniosa de probarlo y
reclutó a Walther Gerlach para ayudarlo a diseñar y realizar el experimento resulta que no probó que Bohr estuviera equivocado sino que
terminó probando que él estaba equivocado su experimento era tan simple y los resultados tan contundentes que prácticamente resolvió el
debate la mecánica cuántica es lo que rige la escala atómica no se dieron cuenta en ese momento
pero el experimento de Stern y Gerlach también encontró evidencia concluyente del spin intrínseco de un electrón que era una
nueva propiedad fundamental de la naturaleza que es esencial para explicar el magnetismo la superconductividad y gran parte de la
química hoy te guiaré a través de cómo funciona el experimento Stern Gerlach qué esperaríamos ver clásicamente
del experimento y qué encontraron Stern y Gerlach entonces te mostraré cómo puedes ejecutar tu propio experimento tipo Stern
Gerlach con Qiskit y una computadora cuántica de IBM la idea básica del experimento Stern
Gerlach era encontrar una manera de determinar si el momento angular de un electrón en un átomo estaba cuantizado como
Bohr predijo o no como Stern esperaba usaron el hecho de que el momento angular del electrón también causaría que
hubiera un pequeño campo magnético alrededor de cada átomo así que puedes pensar en ellos como pequeños imanes de barra
el experimento se veía así había un horno lleno de átomos de plata
y un campo magnético con los polos norte y sur
aquí el campo era más fuerte cerca de la parte superior y más débil cerca de la parte inferior así que produjo un gradiente apuntando hacia arriba
finalmente había una pantalla en el experimento el horno calentaba átomos de plata hasta que se evaporaban y entonces
salían volando del horno con la orientación de cada imán de barra del átomo completamente al azar luego los átomos
pasaban a través del campo magnético los átomos serían empujados hacia arriba o hacia abajo con una fuerza que dependía de la dirección de
cada polo norte del átomo relativo a este gradiente de campo luego los átomos golpeaban la pantalla Stern y Gerlach podían mirar
dónde los átomos golpeaban la pantalla para aprender sobre el momento angular de los electrones Stern esperaba que los átomos
en el experimento se comportaran como he estado describiéndolos hasta ahora como pequeños imanes de barra que obedecen las
reglas de la física clásica clásicamente estos pequeños imanes atómicos podrían estar orientados en cualquier dirección aleatoria así
que mientras viajan a través del campo magnético podrían experimentar una gama de diferentes fuerzas que los empujan hacia arriba o hacia abajo dependiendo de esas orientaciones un imán
apuntando en la misma dirección que el gradiente experimentaría una fuerza grande hacia arriba en la dirección opuesta experimentaría
una fuerza grande hacia abajo y si estuviera en algún lugar intermedio sería una fuerza más débil si el átomo apunta
perpendicular al gradiente entonces no experimentaría ninguna fuerza y simplemente continuaría recto debido a esta
gama de fuerzas posibles los átomos deberían golpear la pantalla en diferentes puntos verticales el patrón que harían
en la pantalla se vería algo como esto pero eso no es todo lo que Stern y
Gerlach vieron en su lugar vieron dos manchas completamente separadas de átomos en la pantalla sin átomos en el
centro no tenían la teoría correcta en ese momento para explicar esto pero ahora sabemos que vieron esto porque
cada electrón tiene una cierta cantidad de momento angular intrínseco en forma de spin que solo puede tomar uno
de dos valores en nuestra imagen de imán de barra esto significa que solo hay dos orientaciones permitidas de los imanes atómicos llamamos
a estas dos orientaciones spin up y spin down un qubit en una computadora cuántica
se asemeja a este tipo de sistema de spin y algunas computadoras cuánticas en realidad usan qubits hechos a partir del spin del electrón
estados así que podemos realizar nuestro propio experimento Stern Gerlach con Qiskit y los qubits en una computadora cuántica de IBM mapeemos
el estado spin up del electrón para ser el estado cero del qubit y el estado spin down para ser el estado uno del
qubit cuando las partículas de plata salieron del horno tenían momentos magnéticos orientados aleatoriamente podemos
modelar el experimento Stern Gerlach creando un circuit cuántico simple con un único qubit comenzando en el estado cero
así que esto se llama un diagrama de circuit donde el cable superior es el qubit y las operaciones aplicadas al qubit
aparecen como cajas en el cable los gates RX y RZ son gates cuánticos que
efectivamente rotan la orientación magnética del átomo podemos elegir valores de Theta y Phi aleatorios aquí para rotar el
qubit una cantidad aleatoria esto imita el horno que expulsa los átomos con orientaciones de spin aleatorias la caja gris es
nuestra medición te dice si el qubit está en el estado cero o uno y envía esa medición a un bit clásico el
línea doble etiquetada C esta parte es equivalente a medir si el átomo está en spin up o spin down mirando
qué lugar golpea en la pantalla podemos usar una primitiva de Qiskit llamada sampler para ejecutar el experimento muchas veces cada uno con
diferentes valores aleatorios para Theta y Phi después de 100 muestras obtenemos un histograma de medición que se ve así alrededor
del 50% del tiempo el qubit se mide como cero y el 50% del tiempo está en estado 1 este es el mismo resultado Stern
y Gerlach vieron siempre es spin up o spin down pero nunca en medio en este punto podrías estar pensando bueno por supuesto
obtuvimos dos resultados discretos realizamos el experimento en una computadora cuántica digital que solo devuelve
cero o uno y esto es verdad pero ten en mente que la razón completa por la que las computadoras cuánticas devuelven resultados binarios de hecho
por qué funciona la computación cuántica en absoluto es exactamente porque esta cuantización de spin que Stern y Gerlach descubrieron primero
los qubits en computadoras cuánticas de IBM no se basan en spins pero muchas otras computadoras cuánticas lo hacen así que realizar un
experimento Stern Gerlach en una computadora cuántica nos permite en realidad redescubrir la cuantización de spin
desde 1922 incontables extensiones al experimento Stern Gerlach original han sido realizadas estas extensiones implican
enviar el mismo haz de átomos a través de múltiples aparatos Stern Gerlach para ver cómo se comportan los spins en diferentes
escenarios aquí hay uno enviemos los átomos a través de un aparato para separar el haz en dos correspondientes a un
haz de spin up y un haz de spin down y luego envíemos cada uno de esos haces a través de sus propios aparatos
separados con Qiskit el circuit cuántico correspondiente a este experimento es similar al último pero con dos
mediciones en lugar de una aquí reemplazamos las rotaciones aleatorias que imitaban el efecto del horno con un
gate llamado Hadamard ya que aplicar el Hadamard nos dará las mismas probabilidades de medición que el horno
hizo pero es mucho más simple de usar así que medimos una vez y luego dos veces y el
histograma de medición resultante para el experimento se ve así donde las cadenas de bits en el eje X corresponden a los
resultados de las dos mediciones si el qubit se midió cero ambas veces eso corresponde a la cadena de bits 00 o si
se midió primero cero luego uno eso corresponde a 01 y así sucesivamente parece que si se midió spin up en
el primer experimento será spin up en el segundo lo mismo con los átomos de spin down eso significa en el primer experimento
teníamos igual probabilidad de medir arriba o abajo pero en el segundo experimento el resultado ya estaba determinado así
las dos pantallas al final de cada uno de los segundos aparatos Stern Gerlach tendrían cada una solo un lugar una pantalla tendría
todos los átomos de spin up y una pantalla tendría todos los átomos de spin down para nuestro próximo experimento vamos a
comenzar con un haz de átomos de spin up puramente con un experimento Stern Gerlach físico real podrías hacer esto enviándolos
a través de un aparato Stern Gerlach y bloqueando el haz que se desvía hacia abajo así que todos los átomos desviados hacia arriba son
spin up ahora enviemos este haz a través de otro aparato Stern Gerlach pero esta vez rotemos los imanes 90° para
que el gradiente de campo desviará los átomos que viajan de esta manera a la izquierda o a la derecha en su lugar veríamos
un lugar o dos o algo completamente diferente para este experimento
ejecutaremos el siguiente circuit en Qiskit comenzaremos en el estado cero ya que nuestro haz de átomos en este experimento son todos
spin up luego este gate Hadamard intercambia las coordenadas x y z para que tenga el efecto de rotar el
aparato Stern Gerlach así que ahora estamos midiendo la proyección de spin izquierda o derecha en lugar de arriba o abajo aquí obtenemos
el histograma de medición que se ve así así que podemos ver que el spin a lo largo de X solo puede tomar dos valores
que podemos llamar spin left y spin right entonces este experimento muestra que si mides la proyección X de un spin
que fue medido previamente para ser spin up a lo largo de Z será spin left o right con igual probabilidad contrastemos
esto una última vez a la expectativa clásica solo para realmente destacar la diferencia clásicamente recuerda que
dije que si el pequeño imán de barra atómico apuntaba perpendicular al gradiente del campo magnético del aparato
la fuerza en ese átomo debería ser cero no debería ser desviado hacia arriba o hacia abajo en ese caso solo vemos un lugar en
el medio de la pantalla en su lugar vemos dos lugares así que la mitad de los átomos tienen spin left y la mitad tienen spin right incluso
aunque fueron medidos previamente para ser up así que desde una perspectiva mecánica cuántica aunque sea tentador
equiparar spin up con un vector apuntando hacia arriba y spin down con uno apuntando hacia abajo no es tan simple como esto como podemos ver
del último experimento para realmente entender qué está sucediendo aquí necesitaremos profundizar en los temas de
superposición cuántica y medición que será un video para otro día así como nos quedamos con más
preguntas sobre cómo exactamente funciona la mecánica cuántica también lo hicieron Stern y Gerlach su experimento no explicó
todo pero fue un gran avance en establecer la mecánica cuántica como esencial para entender lo natural
mundo fue uno de los experimentos fundacionales más importantes en la mecánica cuántica que tanto probó la cuantización
del momento y proporcionó evidencia de una nueva propiedad fundamental de la naturaleza llamada spin para realmente lidiar con y
entender las reglas del mundo cuántico físicos como Stern y Gerlach tuvieron que ensuciarse las manos diseñando
experimentos haciendo predicciones y a veces estando equivocados realmente no hay sustituto para intentar cosas por ti mismo
así que si quieres intentar realizar algunos experimentos cuánticos reales ve al módulo Stern Gerlach
vinculado en la descripción gracias por ver y te veo la próxima vez